repasemos ahora la idea de pendiente que
quizás recuerdes un poco de tus clases
de álgebra o de geometría y
esencialmente la pendiente la podemos
definir para líneas entonces si nosotros
tenemos una línea por aquí muy bien esta
es una una línea bastante agradable
entonces la pendiente la pendiente este
es el concepto que vamos a repasar
esencialmente es la tasa de cambio de
nuestra variable y con respecto a x
verdad o que también podemos verla como
la inclinación una medida de la
inclinación de ésta de esta línea
entonces para calcular eso necesitamos
tomarnos cualesquiera dos puntos
entonces digamos que nos tomamos aquí un
x0 muy bien y este x0 me define aquí
sobre la línea un punto de cero digamos
que este es de cero muy bien entonces
ahora me tengo que tomar otro punto
digamos uno
x 1 este hizo uno que y éste nuevamente
me define un punto sobre la línea verdad
de esta forma muy bien ya este vamos a
llamarle de uno entonces una vez que ya
nos hemos tomado dos puntos sobre la
línea podemos calcular muy bien la
pendiente verdad lo único que tenemos
que hacer es bueno primero vamos a darle
nombre a estos puntos este es el x 0 y
es 0 y este de acá arriba es el x1 de 1
entonces la pendiente la pendiente y
vamos ahora si escribir la definición la
pendiente
esta pendiente no es otra cosa más que
el cociente o la proporción o la
división del cambio entre el cambio en x
y estos cambios están definidos por
estos dos puntos entonces de hecho
sabemos que el cambio y el cambio en x
es está pendiente es constante a lo
largo de toda la línea es decir no
importa a qué par de puntos nos hayamos
tomado este cociente debe ser
exactamente igual muy bien y de hecho en
este caso si la pendiente me está
diciendo que si x va aumentando que
también lleva subiendo verdad entonces
de esta pendiente como se puede calcular
para cualesquiera dos puntos para estos
en particular pues vamos a tener que
calcular el cambio en el cambio en que
sería bueno primero si calculamos el
cambio en x es esta longitud está la
longitud y de hecho es esa longitud no
es otra cosa más que pues x1 menos x0
verdad
x 1 y le quitamos este pedacito
entonces menos x0 muy bien y ahora este
el cambio vertical digamos este cambio
vertical esta distancia es del taller el
camión y recordemos que la delta es una
letra griega que significa justamente
cambio entonces en este caso la delta
será de 1 menos menos de 0 y tú podrás
preguntarme hoy y que no pude haber yo
puesto
0 - llegue 1 / x 0 - x 1 y realmente si
podías realmente si tú pones de 0 menos
de 1 es lo mismo que poner menos de uno
menos 10 0 y si lo haces abajo también
como menos x 1 - x 0 pues los signos se
cancelan verdad el detalle es que hay
que ser consistentes si si al punto
final le restas el inicial pues entonces
debe ser tanto arriba como abajo aquí
está y uno que es el final menos de cero
que es el inicial y abajo está x1 que es
el final menos x0 que es el inicial muy
bien entonces sólo hay que ser
consistentes
habrá ningún problema con eso entonces
esto es lo que ocurre para las líneas
ahora uno puede preguntarse qué pasa si
yo tengo una curva digamos más general
para eso voy a pegar otros ejes ok
déjenme déjenme pegar otros ejes o bueno
bueno quizás debería mejor solo pintarlo
ahí está vamos a poner estos ejes hoy
que se más derecho
que esto está mucho mejor tenemos estos
nuevos ejes nuevamente esto es xy estoy
muy bien entonces qué pasa si tenemos
una curva más general digamos algo así
digamos una curva más o menos de este
estilo muy bien puede uno pensar que es
como una parábola o qué sé yo entonces
vamos a definir también una pendiente y
digamos vamos a tomarnos dos puntos
digamos aquí está un x1 ok y este x1 me
define otro punto aquí sobre la curva y
vamos a llamarle a este y 1 y ahora si
nos tomamos otro x2 digamos este x2 de
aquí este también me va a definir un
punto aquí sobre la curva ya esta altura
le vamos a llamar ye 2 muy bien entonces
lo que yo puedo hacer es calcular la la
pendiente o digamos la tasa de cambio
promedio entre x1 y x2 muy bien entonces
lo que vamos a hacer es exactamente
calcular esto tenemos del talle vamos a
calcular del talle entre delta x
muy bien y que esto no es otra cosa más
que de dos menos de uno es usando la
misma idea de dos menos de 1 / x 2 - x 1
ala delta aquí va un x son muy bien
entonces ya que hemos calculado esto en
realidad aquí estamos calculando nuestra
delta x
esto es delta equis y por acá está
nuestra del taller que es esta distancia
delta y muy bien entonces lo que estamos
haciendo es calcular la tasa de cambio
promedio entre x1 y x2 muy bien es el
cambio de jr respecto de x en este
intervalo y es el cambio promedio ok
pero también lo podemos ver como una
pendiente como una pendiente que pasa de
la recta que pasa por estos dos puntos
entonces construimos la recta que pasa
por estos dos puntos
la recta que pasa por estos dos puntos
y esta es la pendiente que estamos
calculando la de esta línea y por
supuesto a las líneas que cortan una
curva o la gráfica de una función en dos
puntos se les conoce como línea secante
línea secante muy bien así que esto no
es otra cosa más que la pendiente de la
línea secante y estamos tratando de
extender la idea de pendiente para
líneas a pendientes para curvas muy bien
entonces hasta este momento no tenemos
herramientas que nos diga bueno cuál es
la pendiente en este punto sino que
digamos que no dependa de dos puntos
sino cuál es la pendiente aquí que sería
la pendiente de la recta tangente ok
pero no tenemos herramientas pero las
vamos a tener eventualmente sin embargo
hasta ahorita podemos calcular al menos
en la tasa de cambio promedio ok y este
promedio es en un intervalo o lo que es
lo mismo a la pendiente de la línea
secante entonces vamos a irnos
adentrando a la idea de cómo extender
esto para llegar a calcular el cambio
instantáneo
y eso va a ser en la curva imagina que
el punto de aquí este punto de aquí se
va acercando más y más y más y más a
este otro de acá entonces la línea
secante se va apareciendo cada vez más a
esta otra línea que es la línea tangente
y ahí es justamente adónde vamos a
querer llegar eventualmente